this is arthur king and he's an
alcoholic arthur is a 33 year old
husband and father that just can't seem
to put the bottle down and then got
drunk instead he also drank his way
through the service a succession of jobs
and a series of half-hearted cures with
no results but a growing sense of defeat
so he was admitted into the psych ward
spring grove hospital as part of a
special unit called the cottage 13. do
you consider yourself an alcoholic yes
sir definitely it's caused me a lot of
trouble in the past and at this point i
feel that i haven't really accomplished
anything
and i'd like to
start over it was an experimental
program funded by the government to
study how lsd can be used to treat
mental problems so in the fall of 1965
he swallowed an lsd pill and began his
12 hour psychotherapy session
my son became alive in the picture and
it frightened me the rose that was
placed in front of me at times it
appeared to be very bright alive open
full
maybe breathing at times
and after just this one session he never
picked up another drink six months after
his release from the alcoholics ward at
spring grove hospital have you had
anything to drink for example no i
haven't nothing at all and i haven't had
any desire to drink anything arthur's
experiment into the use of lsd was part
of a much larger movement at the time
this was the golden age of psychedelic
research during the 50s and early 60s to
not just cure alcoholism but to use
psychedelics to cure a myriad of things
schizophrenia anxiety disorders
depression autism pain relief in fact
from 1950 to 1966 alone over 2 000
papers were published on the therapeutic
uses of lsd it seemed as if science had
stumbled upon a miracle cure that was
going to change the face of medicine
forever
but then it all came to a grinding halt
[Music]
psychedelics are made a schedule one
drug in 1970 nixon announces drug abuse
as america's public enemy number one
marking the start of the war on drugs
america's public enemy number one
in the united states
is drug abuse in order to fight and
defeat this enemy it is necessary to
wage
a new all-out refuge
and all this psychedelic research grinds
to a halt marking one of the first times
in history that such a promising avenue
of scientific inquiry was stopped
suppressed for reasons that have nothing
to do with the science the government
has successfully suppressed an entire
emerging field of research that was
saving lives mind you so the question is
what happened what changed between the
20 years or so that turned the golden
age of psychedelic research into an
outright prohibition and why is
capitalism falling in love with
psychedelics again today
[Music]
if you want to get into business
yourself you're gonna need some hard
skills that's where skillshare comes in
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes that
help people from all over the world
discover and strengthen their passions
the people that make the most money in
the world today make the most money
because they have the best skills and
that's what skillshare helps you with
there are so many different types of
courses available whether you want to
learn the fundamentals of dslr
photography the five skills to build
creative confidence or how to practice
mindfulness meditation you can find it
all on skillshare but the first course
i'd recommend is simple productivity how
to accomplish more with less by best
selling author greg mcewen it teaches
you how to take control of your life and
focus on the most important things by
following something called essentialism
there are a ton of experts teaching on
skillshare skillshare is constantly
putting out new classes there aren't any
distracting ads or interruptions during
classes and the entire course catalog is
now available with subtitles in spanish
french portuguese and german so if you
want to start improving your skills and
discovering new passions go to
skillshare.com jake to join the first 1
000 of my subscribers to join will get a
one month free trial so you can start
learning on skillshare today seriously
self education totally changed my life
and i love being able to pass this gift
on to you guys so pause the video and
click the link below to join skillshare
now thanks to skillshare for sponsoring
this video
when you think of psychedelics you
probably imagine a bunch of hippie
degenerates in a drum circle or
something but in reality things like
magic mushrooms have been used for
thousands of years in ancient egypt
people believe mushrooms can make you
immortal and were a gift from the god
osiris ancient greece had a famous
psychoactive drink called kikion that
was used by high priests and rituals and
drank by most peasants in india another
powerful psychoactive drink soma was
involved in many ancient religious
festivals and ceremonies they believed
it could impart wisdom and immortality
to those who used it and even before the
start of christianity in europe
mind-altering plants and fungi formed a
big part of pagan festivals and rituals
many believe that our modern day santa
claus was based on the idea of a shaman
who used psychedelics to communicate
with people in the spirit world a little
closer to home peyote a cactus-like
plant with psychoactive properties is
believed to have been used in the
americas for thousands of years with
spanish explorers first recording the
locals using the plan to overcome hunger
and fear in 1519 by 1620 using peyote
was classified as a form of witchcraft
and the spanish believed the drink came
from the devil himself another
psychoactive drink ayahuasca is still
being used for religious and spiritual
ceremonies across south america and they
offer popular retreats for westerners to
try it even though psychedelics were
common across the world for thousands of
years people always seem to want to keep
psychedelics to themselves they were
often designated for use only in
religious ceremonies or by the priests
of the ancient world normal people who
use psychedelics were punished for
participating in something that was seen
as a gift from the gods there's still a
deep mystery surrounding the use of
psychedelics in the ancient world and it
wouldn't be until all the way in 1943
that psychedelics really enters the west
when he swiss chemist discovered lsd and
took 250 micrograms of it
[Music]
there is the kind of mid-century 20th
century uh his history which um begins
with albert hoffmann who is a brilliant
chemist with the sandoz company in
switzerland and he
in effect invents lsd um first in 1938
but he doesn't know what he has yet but
then in 1943 in the middle of world war
ii he got this premonition
that this was a particularly interesting
and beautiful molecule and he and he
should take a second look at it and he
resynthesized it
lsd was discovered by the chemist albert
hoffman who took 250 micrograms of it as
an experiment and proceeded to go on
what we would call today an acid trip he
labeled the drug lsd 25 and the company
he worked for sandoz laboratories
started making the drug available for
research and expectations grew that lsd
could possibly help patients undergo
psychotherapy sandoz is the company you
work for really didn't know what was it
good for how could you use this drug how
could you monetize it as we would say so
sandoz does something very interesting
they
organize you know basically a
a crowd searched research project where
they offer lsd to any researcher
therapist who wants it for free albert
hoffman's lsd trip was the spark that
led to the golden age of psychedelic
research lsd was touted as a wonder drug
and everyone who was anyone doing
scientific research raised to be the
first to determine its beneficial
qualities between the 1950s and 60s
alone more than 2 000 research papers
were written about lsd psilocybin and
other psychedelic drugs more than 40 000
people were given these drugs and
research groups and the industry made
huge leaps in understanding the effects
of psychedelics to treat depression
alcoholism and other mental health
illnesses the power of psychedelics was
so intoxicating even the co-founder of
alcoholics anonymous experimented with
lsd and found it to be more effective
than the 12-step program he helped
create even the churches got behind
psychedelics with some people finding it
could inspire and enhance unique
religious experiences
unfortunately the psychedelic craze also
attracted the attention of the cia which
led to the dark side of the psychedelic
age the cia's mk ultra experiments
the first government-backed research
into psychedelic started in boston in
1949 it was secretly funded by the cia
and us army and by 1951 reports claimed
that the soviet union had purchased
around 50 million doses of lsd from
sandoz laboratories afraid of what the
soviets could be doing with it the cia
launched a series of weird and sometimes
horrifying psychedelic experiments on
the u.s population to weaponize lsd
tests were done to see if lsd could work
as a truth serum experiments were
conducted to determine if it can make
soviet spies defect or if spraying lsd
on enemy troops could work as a weapon
of mass distraction lse was even given
without consent to mental patients
prisoners workers of the world's oldest
profession and drug addicts quote people
who could not fight back end quote as
one agency officer put it so they could
study its effects in many cases lse was
given to people without them knowing the
cia even set up brothel experiments
where they would give men who went to
lebron though lsd without their
knowledge so they could blackmail them
into not speaking out about it if they
found out aka operation midnight climax
the government took it so far as to use
lsd to torture people for information
threatening them that their trip would
continue forever if they didn't share
their secrets people died and were
seriously debilitated in this line of
research and a substance that has been
shown so much promise had been turned
into a weapon against the same people it
was supposed to help but then something
happened that would forever change the
course of psychedelics in the west
taking it from the golden age of
research and slowly eroding it into
prohibition and it all started with the
vice president of jp morgan gordon
watson him and his family participated
in a mushroom ceremony in mexico in 1955
by his account he was the first white
man to participate in this ritual and he
wrote about his experience in the 1957
issue of life magazine the article went
viral and was the catalyst that brought
lsd and psychedelics into the public
spotlight from the moment that article
went live it will mark the beginning of
the death of psychedelics from a miracle
cure to the number one threat to society
just 10 years later what happened
between 1957 and 1968 that caused
opinions on psychedelics to change so
dramatically
[Music]
the 1960s ushered in an era of social
upheaval under the burden of the vietnam
war widespread racial discrimination the
cold war the rebellious hippie culture
emerged and the activists of the time
really believed that they could change
mainstream culture the substance of
choice for this new counter-culture lsd
psychedelics quickly escaped from the
labs and made their way to the streets
where they became a recreational
sensation and lsd became the party drug
of the decade and also as a sign of
rebellion at the time the research on
lsd continued and one of those
researchers was a guy named timothy
leary he was a lecturer and behavioral
psychologist at harvard university and
went to mexico to try mushrooms for
himself that trip he said taught him
more in 15 minutes than he had learned
in 15 years as a therapist and he came
back to the states eager to test the
drug's other therapeutic properties so
larry partnered with richard albert and
founded the harvard still assignment
project to research psychedelics at
harvard psilocybin is the active
chemical and magic mushrooms and since
psychedelics were so new to the west
back then people often treated
psilocybin lsd and other psychedelics as
the same thing so they decided to test
lsd on prisoners addicts church members
college students and themselves which
drew a ton of criticism from the press
lsd quickly escaped the last which led
to students using it a black market form
near harvard a hippie commune formed
near the school forcing the school to
ban the drug and eventually fire the two
researchers but leary was a true
believer in how psychedelics could
transform society so he formed the
international foundation for internal
freedom eventually reinventing himself
as the high priest of psychedelics
leading the counterculture movement in
america setting up communes telling the
youth to turn on tune and drop out from
society the war the government
corporations etc in other words this new
movement went against everything the
establishment and government stood for
it went against the war effort it went
against consumerism that feel the
economy it went against authority and it
was all fueled in part by lsd and other
psychedelics richard nixon called leary
the most dangerous man in america he
felt that lsd
and other drugs were sapping the will of
american boys to fight in vietnam and he
may well have been right i mean lsd
encourages people to think for
themselves to not accept the frames of
social values the games that that we
play uh socially
and in important ways lsd did fuel the
counterculture and was very threatening
to adult society and to the powers that
be so in 1966 lsd is banned sandoz the
company that was making lsd stops
producing it and the ban is followed by
dozens of reports of the sudden
discovery of the dangers of the
substance all experiments on lsd came to
an end and one of the most promising
drugs of the 20th century becomes an
illegal narcotic two years later
psilocybin is banned and the prohibition
on second deluxe turns into a full-blown
war on drugs
[Music]
this is your brain this is drugs
this is your brain on drugs any
questions
america's public enemy number one
in the united states
is drug abuse in order to fight and
defeat this enemy it is necessary to
wage
a new all-out function
in an unprecedented move in science
psychedelics are made an illegal
schedule 1 substance not because it was
proven that they were actually dangerous
but because it was a threat to the
government's power and because it made
for a good political tool this is what
jon erlichman nixon's own domestic
policy advisor had to say about the true
intentions behind the war on drugs the
nixon campaign in 1968 and the nixon
white house after that had two enemies
the anti-war left and black people we
knew we couldn't make it illegal to be
either against the war or black but by
getting the public to associate hippies
with marijuana and psychedelics and
blacks with heroin and then
criminalizing both heavily we could
disrupt those communities we could
arrest their leaders raid their homes
break up their meetings and vilify them
night after night on the evening news
did we know we were lying about the
drugs of course we did
[Music]
the scheduling for psychedelics also
made no sense schedule 1 drugs are
classified as having the highest risk
for abuse and psychological or physical
dependence however most researchers
agree that psychedelics are actually
anti-addictive meaning that their
effects are weakened the more frequently
you take them meanwhile drugs like
cocaine and meth which are way more
addictive and dangerous aren't even as
high on the scheduling list before
psychedelics psychiatry had been stuck
in the 19th century but not even these
developments can make up for the mess
llc and psilocybin had created in the
eyes of the government decades of work
and research was wasted and this gave
way to a generation of adults and
doctors who were taught that
psychedelics were nothing more than
dangerous substances with no benefit to
society and by the end of the 1970s for
most people lsd is nothing but an
old-fashioned mistake from the past
the research dies out and we enter into
the dark ages of psychedelic research
[Music]
in the end it took more than two decades
for research on psychedelics to begin
again in 1992 dr rick strassman started
studying dmt dmt dmt dmt dmt gmt that
same year the fda passed the
prescription drug user fee act to
encourage research on new drugs and
since dmt wasn't as well known or as
stigmatized as other psychedelics dmt
studies were approved far more easily
then in 1999 john hopkins hospital
restarted its own psychedelic research
with private funding and psychotherapy
started gaining traction again and ever
so slowly the research picked back up
the stigma slowly went away bit by bit
into today the renaissance of
psychedelics
[Music]
today the war and dress has come under
serious scrutiny and in the case of
psychedelics a glimmer of hope can be
seen one of the biggest victories
against the war on drugs in the u.s was
the legalization of psychedelic therapy
in oregon this was part of the vote to
decriminalize the possession of all
drugs even washington dc talked about
decriminalizing all psychedelic plants
and the research has been growing
exponentially as well studies find that
psilocybin can help build new
connections between brain cells trials
show that ecstasy and counseling could
help people with severe ptsd and
research has finally proven that
psychedelics are not addictive don't
cause organ damage and don't make holes
in your brain one of the more popular
psychedelics today mdma which is also
known as ecstasy or molly is showing a
lot of promise with helping with ptsd
and is one of the most exciting research
paths right now and all this progress
decriminalization promising research and
a much more open mind from the public
has sparked a gold rush into the
psychedelic industry and universities
entrepreneurs wall street and venture
capitalists want in as michael poland
puts it capitalism is falling in love
with psychedelics right now
recently harvard researcher david
sinclair talked about how e-doctor
mental health startups would be the next
billion dollar companies because of the
mental health crisis caused by social
media
crazy age
it's fun but stressful stress for a lot
of people well and for your study for
the study of human life extension and
anti-aging when you look at the stresses
that are completely they're very novel
to the human experience like the
stresses of social media the stresses of
cell phone use the stresses of blue
light like staring at screens at night
like all that stuff like how much of an
effect do you think that's having on
people and have we even quantified that
yet we are quantifying it and it's
having a real negative effect mental
health issues is going to be the medical
problem of the 21st century no question
there are companies that are doing these
uh
remote video chats with a psychologist
or
psychiatrist they are booming these are
the next billion dollar companies
yeah you wanna anyone wanna make money
look into that the anxiety depression
and stress caused by social media that
would make these e-doctor startups
billion dollar companies could very well
be the same reason why psychedelic
startups may be the next billion dollar
companies as well they say it's only a
matter of time before the fda approves
the use of psychoactive drugs and
therapy and many believe mdma would be
legalized by 2023 with psilocybin just a
few years after that so the best
universities in the country like yale
john hopkins the university of
california and berkeley are racing to
prepare laboratories and trials to study
psychedelics while investors are
emptying their pockets into startups and
independent research labs are simply
waiting for the okay before making their
products available after almost 50 years
of secrecy government propaganda and
lies surrounding the dangers of
psychedelics psychedelics are once again
on the verge of taking the scientific
and recreational world by storm with all
that's happening around the legalization
of psychedelics and their research a few
key players have popped up in the
industry field trip health a canadian
company that runs high-end ketamine
clinics across the us right now they're
focusing on developing a new psychedelic
therapy that is as strong as psilocybin
but works in around half the time my med
uses psychedelic inspired therapy and
microdoses of lsd to help patients reap
the benefits without experiencing a
full-blown trip compass pathways is a
mental health facility currently
investing 240 million dollars into
clinical trials on psilocybin across 10
different countries while thai life
sciences is a biopharma company that
makes all of compass trials possible
[Music]
as a society we've elevated some
substances to the center of our society
while irrationally demonizing a ton of
others that could potentially be
beneficial because of the war on drugs
we've lumped them all together even
though so many of them are completely
different stimulants depressants
psychedelics that have all been squeezed
into this one-size-fits-all thing when
it comes to how to integrate them into
society caffeine is an example of a
substance that's perfectly integrated
into society in fact caffeine is kind of
field capitalism quote the coffee break
tells you all you need to know about the
links between capitalism and caffeine
the idea that your employer would give
you a free drug and then pay time in
which to enjoy it tells you everything
end quotes
[Music]
alcohol is also relatively well
integrated into society even though it's
addictive we have norms like you
probably shouldn't drink until the
evening it's one o'clock in the
afternoon and you're pissed ass drunk
and yet with all the promises of
psychedelics it's not integrated in
society at all but it could be and it
wouldn't be too far off to imagine a
world where psychedelic retreats trip
guides psychedelic therapy could all be
commonplace like some companies are
already trying to do
have you done psychedelics before if you
have what was your experience was it
good was it terrifying let me know in
the comments below and also what you
guys think about psychedelics and the
legalization of them as well as i
mentioned before i've never done
psychedelics before and i didn't want to
do them before this video because i
didn't want to come off as just some
hippie that does mushrooms that made
this video so that you can make them
legal to enjoy more mushrooms i didn't
want that image but i am not saying that
it's off the table for the future if you
are new here we make video essays just
like this one every single week on the
most provocative thought-provoking stuff
in the world of business all the way
from why do chinese billionaires
disappear to why haven't we seen
hyperinflation yet to the economics of
the mafia if you subscribe you will not
regret it i can promise you that and if
you do you can always dislike
unsubscribe and leave me your best hate
comments in the comments below so you
have nothing to lose and everything to
gain if you want more behind the scenes
stuff than the live kind of stuff you
can follow me on instagram at jtrend.io
and that is going to wrap up this video
i hope you enjoyed it thank you so much
for watching you've been awesome i've
been jake stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you